[Music]
everybody's making like [ __ ] three
hour long documentaries we need to we
need to [ __ ] pull like hit the break
on the documentaries so you don't like
them it's fine but it's like holy [ __ ]
everybody has to have a complex essay
yeah yeah you know the biggest thing I'm
tired on is [ __ ] the rise and fall
videos yes profiting off of people like
yes they make me so sad because a lot of
them are like V2 yeah okay so the one
the one that specifically 2988 was a
person that at a time was at his Peak
dude the one that I hate from him is the
LMFAO one because it's like dude they
did they had a great career yeah they're
both happy guys it's just like
documentary makes it seem like that
every foolish business decisions and
it's like [ __ ] off it's like if they die
in a fire why is this it's the same kind
of [ __ ] of like the reason why I don't
like keemstar anybody where it's like
people that are like profiting off of
like the demise of something not that
you have to like just cherish everybody
but [ __ ] sakes your whole brand is
just like this person sucks and here's
why it's like yeah off oh yeah I've done
videos like that
I can't be too critical well I guess the
thing too is like if you fully believe
that the vid well because probably the
video that you did was somebody that you
don't respect or like you're like I this
is just like it's funny to watch this
person who
was maybe malicious in a way get their
comeuppance that's different than just
like buggy or like I don't know I
thought I'm trying to defend anybody I
don't know I'm just saying that I just
don't if I [ __ ] hate it it's like
everything that's what commentaries have
turned into now though is either
documentary [ __ ] or it's people that are
just like doing like an in-depth [ __ ]
60 Minute thing about the demise of
somebody what do you like on YouTube you
know what you know what I love on
YouTube there's this guy I can never
remember the name he reviews uh axes
wood like wood cutting axes nice he's a
guy that lives in Canada and he's like
literally just like oh this is a good
one it's just like a nice [ __ ] literally
I just like when people are passionate
about something that feels genuine yeah
and I like when people also like I
appreciate like highly edited videos too
and so I I everything I just want people
to be genuine because it's just so
[ __ ] easy to see when things are for
money and when things are just to like
follow Trends and stuff it's just yeah I
don't know I I love I I actually love
YouTube I love the environment of
YouTube I like feeling like people have
fun things to make or say about new
things or whatever it's just I love it
but it's actually it's actually one of
the things I really enjoy about building
a channel from scratch again is that
about like a certain sort of Niche is
that like all the comments are about
that thing and everything is kind of
like geared towards that it comes with
like this General like oh you're not
funny anymore it's more like about this
like progress that I'm trying to make I
could Escape those yeah yeah I could
Escape that I'm not funny exactly and
it's just about working out yeah people
love my fitness yeah no uh I don't know
it just comes with like people being
passionate about things and other people
being
like also passionate about that like
it's not you being an expert it's just
about you making something entertaining
about something that people also find
like enjoyable or whatever I think that
like that's fun and like a lot of people
that I watch too it's not like they're
like [ __ ] experts about the thing
it's just like they know how to be
charismatic on camera and they know how
to but talk about things that I find
enjoyable too that's all yeah so leave
my Formula One commentary alone okay
that's for me yeah so you and your seven
viewers who are also yeah Italian
millionaires yeah enjoy it no no
F1 is huge now dude it's gigantic dude
maybe not here no in the states it's
[ __ ] huge now yeah in this come on
bro that's Vegas yes it is yeah where
everywhere
yeah the drive to survive documentary
blew it up uh Formula One they did make
I think I remember hearing driver's five
it was very like
uh sensationalized right and stuff like
extremely yeah what you got you got to I
think to survive the stage you gotta
have that [ __ ] yeah it's so funny but
it's like when you run into those fans
and then they start saying [ __ ] about
Formula One it's just like nails on
chalkboard you're like oh damn that's
what I feel about people like NASCAR
yeah we're like yeah NASCAR and people
say like NASCAR's huge but it's like
it's a very select
people that enjoy it yeah versus like
the NBA or ml like major league baseball
that's going to be [ __ ] insane
in the city the Formula One bought and
they're building a facility there and I
think it'll be the first track owned by
Formula One and it'll be in
like here or in America it's either this
or whatever yeah I don't know if the
race is though that's that's super fun
that's insane that it's like you're
racing the strip I don't know how good
the race will be
the engines May blow up it's like very
long straights that's just going to be
pretty taxing I think see this it almost
reads like a NASCAR track this one with
that long yeah yeah but you know they'll
be doing over 200 miles an hour down
that and that's [ __ ] awesome now
that's gonna be sick to see and if you
because you've been to F1 twice like
what's a good see is it just finish line
is that the best seat
um it really depends on the track like
some tracks you can I would say if you
can get a seat near like
um
like s's or like Fast corners
sorry we're looking on your phone uh
just [ __ ]
two polish or two Russian Rockets
accidentally cross into Poland and kill
two people that's that's good to know
it's really good news yeah okay
potentially world war three started you
see the thing that happened in Dallas
with the airplanes that connected yeah
that was insane yeah dude that video is
so sad [ __ ] brutal so how did that
even happen what are the odds of that
happening
it's tough yeah yeah but yeah get a seat
near some s's because I I hate to
whatever just
yeah just by the turns not not all of
them like because because some some
Corners are slow it's a stupid statement
though no it is no it is it's not it's
not a pointed statement it's not stupid
but it's not it's reductive all right
dude I'm just saying some pockets of the
circuit are different the [ __ ]
scientist of f they're slow Corners
there's fast Corners all I'm getting
that is there are certain corners and
like s's that really demonstrate like
the speed at which these cars can corner
and it's [ __ ] insane when you see the
cars like get up to speed and then you
see them like compress into the Earth
and they're just like an airplane on the
ground it's the most bizarre looking
thing that I mean literally any part of
the track is pretty amazing outside of a
slow corner
that's cool dude
hey uh can we get another shot for him
his blood sugar is getting all [ __ ] up
I have been drinking during both these
podcasts have you really yeah oh wow I'm
kind of drunk right now nice yeah sorry
about that
that's why I do as soon as I as soon as
I came in I was like I bet you anything
that Jack is exactly the amount I had oh
yeah but I'm like yep knew they'd put it
there
yeah we're heading to Chili's after this
guys yeah thanks for tuning in for the
bonus yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] pin Hunter
down and make him like sports and make
him watch [ __ ] race cars no man watch
I'm gonna make him watch Aiden Ross and
formula one
laughs
come here come here
I should have prepared you for my ice
cream
yeah that was that was real I got a nice
like girl high-pitched scream I can't no
it's too loud it's embarrassing you have
a beautiful voice you can sing I can't
sing actually
ah I can't see
it's kind of a late reaction I'm
actually I hate to say it and I'm not
I'm not a person who boasts a lot right
I'm not a very boastful person okay but
I will say I am one hell of a person to
go to karaoke with
and I'm not somebody who too who's just
like it's just like someone's like oh
he's gonna sing that and it's like good
it's like I pick fun songs and I can
boost everybody up I like to make people
comfortable we'll see
the song I love to do at karaoke is the
song that he played earlier and I also
like uh play the backing track and you
sing us out I'm not gonna do that here
come on man just posted about how
I'm gonna boast about but I'm not gonna
do it pre-recorded for this
why not it's just [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign